hey this is presh to Walker I came
across an interesting paper when masters
of abstraction run into a concrete wall
experts failing arithmetic word problems
the abstract asks can knowledge about
apples cars or Smurfs hinder our ability
to solve mathematical problems involving
these entities
they actually found experts were failing
at certain word problems
are you going to run into the same issue
to find out let's do a simple
two-question quiz
question one
slouchy Smurf is a certain height he
climbs on a Smurf table he now attains
the height of 14 centimeters
grouchy Smurf climbs on the same table
as slouchy Smurf grouchy Smurf is two
centimeters shorter than slouchy Smurf
what height does grouchy Smurf attain
when he climbs on the table
given the data provided is it possible
to find a solution a no there is not
enough information to find the solution
B yes and the correct answer is blank
you need to figure out the correct
answer
now question two
in the store Anthony wants to buy a
ruler costing a certain price he also
wants a notebook in total that will cost
him 14 dollars
Julie wants to buy the same notebook as
Anthony and an eraser the Eraser costs
two dollars less than the ruler how much
will Julie have to pay
given the data provided is it possible
to find a solution a no there is not
enough information to find the solution
B yes and the correct answer is blank
fill in the correct answer
so let's go over the answers to these
questions so question one slouchy Smurf
is a certain height he climbs on a Smurf
table he now attains a height of 14
centimeters
so we have a table we'll represent
slouchy Smurf by a mushroom and he's on
top of the table and the total height is
14 centimeters
grouchy Smurf climbs on the same table
as slouchy Smurf and he is two
centimeters shorter
so we subtract two centimeters what
height does grouchy Smurf attained well
this will be 14-2 which is of course
equal to 12 centimeters so the correct
answer is yes there is enough
information and the correct answer is 12
centimeters
now question two
in the store Anthony wants to buy ruler
costing a certain price he also wants a
notebook in total that will cost him 14
dollars
so if R is the price of the ruler n is
the price of the notebook we have R plus
n is equal to fourteen dollars
Julie wants to buy the same notebook as
Anthony and an eraser so we can denote
this as n plus e
the Eraser costs two dollars less than
the ruler so e is equal to R minus two
how much will Julie have to pay
well we will substitute in for E so we
have n plus r minus two
but then n plus r is equal to R plus n
which is equal to 14 so this is equal to
14 minus 2 which is equal to 12. so
Julie will have to pay twelve dollars so
the correct answer is B and the correct
answer is twelve dollars
how did you do did you find one question
was easier than the other
now both of these questions are testing
the same arithmetic problem of 14 minus
2 which is equal to 12. the two
questions are isomorphic to each other
however the participants did not find
the two questions to be the same
question two was asking about price and
question one was asking about height
is a kind of number that we imagine on
an Axis or a number line which is an
ordered number
we think about distance duration and
Floors as types of ordinal numbers
on the other hand price is a type of
number we think more about as a
collection of a set
so we think about collections price
weight these have a size but they're not
in any particular order and we call
these cardinal numbers
so what the authors of the study found
is there was a difference in how the
participants responded for the two types
of numbers
for the questions that involved ordinal
numbers the adults were able to solve 82
percent of the questions correctly
for the cardinal numbers however they
only solved 47 percent of the questions
correctly they found these to be much
harder and they took longer to solve
them
now interestingly they also tested
mathematical experts
these were people who passed the ecole
normal Superior entrance exam which is
extremely difficult entrance exam that
only two percent of people passed
successfully
so how did the experts do you would
imagine these are trivial questions for
them
well for the ordinal number of questions
the experts solved this with a 95 rate
minus a few slip UPS they pretty much
solve ordinal number questions but for
Cardinal number questions only 76
percent gave the correct answer
now this is an amazing thing it's much
smaller and even more is that one in
four experts struggled if the phrasing
involved Cardinal quantities this is
absolutely mind-boggling
so I think there are three lessons you
can take from this study first word
choice of a question is very important
second beware of this bias even if you
can solve complicated arithmetic and
mathematical problems you might trip up
on an easy question just because of the
word choice
finally don't blindly trust experts
while they are experts and they can
figure out the solution if they
understand the question things like word
choice and semantics can matter to
whether they actually understand the
question
so it's okay if you question them and
you should be aware of this bias
what an interesting study
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign